c'est donc ce matin au large de la
bretagne qu'à pétrolier maltais s'est
ouvert en deux dans une mer déchaînée 12
décembre 1999 le pétrolier erika du
naufrage au large des côtes bretonnes
vingt mille tonnes de fioul se déverse
dans l'atlantique les nappes de fioul
déry toujours vers le sud à une vitesse
moyenne de 2 km heure alors que la marée
noire n'a pas encore touché le littoral
des communes menacées par la pollution
prennent les devants elles font appel à
corinne lepage avocate et figure du
procès de l'amoco cadiz en 1984 la
mission est double voir ce qui se passe
avant et si la catastrophe à rire voir
ce qui se passe après pour permettre
précisément l'indemnisation des victimes
le plus rapidement possible le 23
décembre
onze jours après la catastrophe les
premières nappes de pétrole touche les
côtes françaises plages souillées
galettes de pétrole échoué tout le long
de la côte et des oiseaux par dizaines
prise au piège et que l'on tente en vain
souvent de sauver les communes se
retrouve en première ligne sont des
premières à nettoyer les plages mais
l'opération est coûteuse
corinne lepage demande alors à total
affrêteur de l'erika d'assumer
financièrement ses responsabilités voilà
des mois que les maires demandent à
total de nettoyer les plages ils ont
pris des arrêtés en ce sens
rien n'a été fait par total ou très peu
en 2008 plus de huit ans après le
naufrage
le procès de l'erika s'ouvre pour la
première fois la justice reconnaît le
préjudice écologique
le principe du pollueur payeur est lui
aussi appliquée résultat quatre prévenus
dont total sont condamnés à verser 192
millions d'euros de dommages et intérêts
aux parties civiles
un verdict salué par l'avocate corinne
lepage ce qu'a dit le tribunal c'est du
bon sens et d'écouté totale vous avez
contrôler ce bateau vous avez donné un
feu vert vous avez accepté de le prendre
vous saviez qu'il était un mauvais état
avait commis une imprudence et voilà en
la peine est confirmée par la cour de
cassation c'est la fin d'un long combat
judiciaire pour corinne lepage 13 ans
après le naufrage de l'erika
treize ans de bataille de la part des
collectivités locales que j'ai eu
l'honneur de réforme mais c'est aussi je
pense un très grand jour pour tous les
défenseurs de l'environnement d'où
l'émotion qui est la mienne aujourd'hui
si le principe de préjudice écologique a
été appliquée pour la première fois lors
du procès erika il a fallu attendre 2016
pour qu'il soit inscrit dans le code
civil grâce à la loi sur la biodiversité
[Musique]